[Music]
i remember the first girl i was really
like in love with when i was a teenager
and i remember working up the courage
to go over to her house and tell her how
i felt i remember being
incredibly difficult i really psyched
myself up and uh i just gotten my
driver's license maybe my permit and
that song by the cranberry's dreams had
recently come out and i was obsessed
with it i was listening to it
constantly so and it was one in the days
when you had tape players so you'd have
to rewind it and i pulled into her
driveway and my parents pontiac
bonneville wood paneling on the side
station wagon and blasting oh my
turn the car off went inside uh and just
declared how i felt and i just did it
she turned me down in a very sweet way
we were still friends we ended up going
out a couple years later but i got back
in my car i would try to play it cool oh
yeah sure oh i get no don't worry got
back in my car and um started crying i
took a moment and i uh
i started crying then i noticed her in
the window of her house kind of looking
out i pretended everything was okay
again i went back down and waved and
smiled and i turned on the car and i
forgot that i've been blasting dreams by
the cranberries and it came on again
full blast and i didn't want to then
turn down the song immediately because i
didn't want her to think that i i
thought that was awkward so i just kept
the song playing full blast pulling out
of her driveway smiling at her hoping
she wouldn't see the tears
well maybe if you had showed up with a
boombox over your head things would have
been different for you yeah i know i i
had seen that movie and i idolized john
q's i like how you slipped into that
story that it worked out a couple years
later
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my
also uh teenage
lover you'd be what well as no no and
i'd like you're also in addition to my
brother you're my teenage lover oh boy
you had been at one point a teenager in
love yes of course and did your first
one the first one that you uh
was in love just jumped into my head
i thought it was why must that be a
teenager in life teenager in love oh
that's your version i mean that's your
part of the song oh would you stop with
the bubbles during oh sorry
you don't know you're doing it
you don't know you're doing it
um
why must so your your base part when you
were in your band your occupant yes it
was just teenagers no no no there's a
lot more to it than that
um
but yes i was i was a teenager
now i'm thinking about uh free angsty
very emo
that time you know oh yeah well i'm
telling storm about how i cried in my
car at the cranberries but you were
angsty i was saying they were emo they
were emo yeah
if that's not emo i don't know what emo
is yeah that's true i wonder if she if i
wonder if i ever told her that i was
crying at this point as a 42 year old
man i don't think it's something to be
particularly embarrassing i'm not no no
no you were a kid the idea of her seeing
me crying then was so embarrassing that
i think i'm i'm thinking about it as a
teenager
from in that brain using that brain
right is still kind of embarrassed by it
well you shouldn't be because it's like
a different person though it's like but
now but now for a man to show his
vulnerable emotional side it's like the
most woke cool thing you can do what
what who was your uh first love of your
first or the one in high school that you
declared your love to and did it work
out
oh it always worked out
uh first time you were like i gotta get
i gotta tell you you know i i never
really
openly did that i don't think i ever
like
nor have i ever really we've talked
about this i think i've never really
approached a stranger and started a
convert like a stranger that i was
attracted to and started a conversation
never i don't think so
i mean i'm not saying i it happens often
but it's it's very rare for me i mean
i'm with you
i've like met strangers in the past but
it's usually when i'm like out with
some friends and
someone's that disabled next there's
yeah there's a conduit yeah like
something um brings me there of course
yeah but just to like approach i know
i don't think i've ever done it you know
both have a hard time approaching female
strangers it just seems especially now
in this climate it feels so like it's
predatory i i can't imagine doing it i i
don't know
unless like you said there was some
something happen like
some anything any event even if it's
somebody dropped something or yeah
yeah but why are we talking about young
love and our heartbreak young heartbreak
right break uh i was a kid when this
happened when this heartbreak occurred
oh
yeah yeah i was technically a 15 that's
a kid that's a kid especially you
because i looked like i was eight so
you're a kid you were going through a
heartbreak and as faye would have it our
guest today
was in a film called the heartbreak kid
that's right our guest today is the very
beautiful very funny
warm easy
one of my favorites what's her name i'm
getting there okay
very patient
huh
marlon ackerman well she's swedish do i
generalize a lot about people i feel i'm
wonderful you generalized a lot about
canadians and swedes i know that's
that's specifically what i was thinking
of and um
this is what i think i it's safe to say
i have yet to meet a swedish person
that i didn't at least really like have
you met ten or more swedish people i bet
i have
i'm thinking of five of them now six i'm
sure crew members in london
swedish people i've never had a bad
swedish experience either a swedish
person who was like
unfriendly or uh was
rude or you know i just it hasn't
happened to me yet and i'm sure they
exist of course of course they exist of
course they're out there um and maybe
one of you listening has had that kind
of experience and i'd love to hear about
it you know i've had good finnish
experiences too yes and norwegian i mean
it's scandinavians i don't have uh
danish a lot of norwegian experience but
uh
a little bit yeah
i know i
aside from just being swedish is also a
very talented actress i've never seen
her give a false note you know i've
never seen her like act she's just such
a natural and funny and you know that's
why she plays a lot of uh co-leads in
like romantic comedies to well we were
mentioning harper kid that's ben stiller
plays opposite vince vaughn in couple's
retreat she's and we get into this she
seems so uh self-assured when it comes
to
her
role in those movies that she seems that
she can go up against comedic titans
like that and she always holds her own
she always
you know brings something fresh and
natural to a role like that right she
was also in the watchmen yeah yeah
that's right what a fun movie i really
love that movie she's on the show
billions yes you've known her for a long
time your old friends old friends old
friends through a former guest i guess
the show emanuel shriki you've never
experienced heartbreak with her though
no but i imagine um there's heartbreak
potential sure with she possesses that
she sure does yeah right don't you think
yeah i think she's uh there's not i
don't know her well but i've met her a
few times and she is very impressive
person i'm sure there are things oh of
course she has flaws but here's the
thing everyone has flaws and she
one of my favorite traits is she kind of
owns those flaws she's like she's very
honest person let's hear it okay
you can hear her in all her uh
glory her charming glory the
incredibly charming very funny
old friend of mine marlon eckman life
could be a dream
hello hello again you're blooming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
whatever happened to your mom's
the amazing race oh the survive the
swedish survivor that's what it was yeah
yeah oh my god she killed it i mean she
lasted
four weeks out of 10. she's 70. all
right
she like beat out you know
oh what's it called in english now where
you like squat down you're leaned
against a wall but you're in sit
position like it's like you're sitting
on a chair but you're not sitting on
anything you're then you're leaning
against a wall oh this isn't sad i don't
know this i'm sad for two reasons
english is my only language and uh
it's
it's an exercise move um
what is that anyway it's one of those if
you just like squatted down and you put
your back against the wall and you try
to like sit yeah like that kind of a
thing yeah
and they had they did a competition on
how long you hold off that's hard
she can hold it for nine minutes
get out of here oh my god seven year old
woman oh yeah i can hold it for maybe
two maybe if i'm on a really good day oh
my god i'm doing it right now for if
anyone's listening that's really hard
holy [ __ ]
nine minutes
so they're like feats of strength like
that is it the same exactly oh wow yeah
so she beat out a lot of like young men
who were in their 40s it was pretty
incredible but then she got basically
the starvation got to her she was
starting to get dizzy and faint
because she wasn't getting enough foods
and then she thought you know what i am
70 i'm not gonna push it too too much
further but strength-wise she was
incredible i thought she had maybe just
been predisposed to that kind of a
competition like you said no she this
was a like a brand new just like a spur
of the moment well she's been a dancer
and a fitness instructor her whole life
yeah so he's also a viking i mean oh
okay so she was sort of predisposed to
it
yeah
in some ways yeah
oh my god well always out
were you able to spend time with her
have you seen her since all this
happened you know what we ended up going
to sweden in june at the end of june
my dad lives in a small little beach
town
in the south of sweden my mom lives on
an island um
and so we ended up going out covet had
already sort of passed through my dad's
beach town oh my god and him my sister
is down there and they have a new baby
and all of her
baby daddy's family had got coveted and
my dad and stepmom had been hanging out
with they had all been like interlaced
together luckily my dad didn't get it
but obviously he had been exposed to it
wow
weird thing about kobet where it's like
you know the mom and dad of my sister's
man is called adam um i won't call him
the baby
the mom didn't get it and the dad and
the sisters and everyone else got it
as soon as they found out it was kind of
like well
we've all been hanging out so we're all
gonna either have it or not
but anyway it had passed through and we
thought all right and that was already
in like
april probably wow so we just thought
well well this is a perfect opportunity
because they've all been exposed and you
know
probably an antibodies probably and my
husband has antibodies and i don't have
anything so it's like it's super weird
did he get it at all did he have any
symptoms no nothing he was one of those
asymptomatic people i'm fascinated by
how sweden is responding to this because
they're just dealing with it in a very
swedish way yeah yeah in a very swedish
way that's very well put yeah it is it's
a lot of people died in the beginning
right um let's be honest you know a lot
of elderly because they didn't it just
kind of swept through all the old age
homes they have pulled back a lot now in
sweden but it is it's a small country
and so it's easier to control and i feel
like sweden is very logical just in
general in the way that they approach
things it's not very fair fear-based
it's not very religious based
and so
um
a lot of times i feel like here in
america as much as it is absolutely real
there's no question about it it's just
there's so much fear that's put put into
so many aspects of it right instead of
going all right these are the facts
um and it's terrible so now you guys
have to take care of yourselves and your
life is in your hands and we're gonna
take the precautions we can as a
government um but here's what we suggest
and that's it instead of going this is
the fact
yeah exactly just give the facts and
then move on from there and let's do our
best but i agree with you the problem is
and we might have to cut this out
because it's inherently insulting what
i'm about to say about americans is that
swedes to me are
i mean it doesn't this show isn't this
like indicative of uh i mean you don't
have to answer this but it strikes me
that
how they've approached this and how
other countries are approaching this um
speaks to a general attitude that people
have about countries have about
communal living and how and how
much they care about one another
this thing has just amplified
my
suspicions about certain you know
cultures we don't have to get into it
but um you guys are the best i mean
swedes you're just the best swedes and
canadians and come to find out you are a
combination of both
i am a combination of both yes yeah i
love the love that i'm getting right now
oh and i'm holding back this is like i'm
playing it very cool
oh all right all right you don't wanna
you don't wanna give too much right away
no i've let it trickle i'm a very gushy
person and um
i've i love hanging out with you all the
time every time i'm around you it's so
fun
but um
so i got over our time in um in new york
you were doing that festival at the
theater
yes in williamstown in williamson
but oh my god we had such a great night
after
so fun why were you there you were
shooting a movie in upstate new york i
was shooting a movie with dan stevens oh
yeah dan stevens knew chris abbott
that's doing right
yeah and then we got with um sam
rockwell sam was there and we all went
out
some dinner after so it's so funny you
mentioned chris because i just saw him
again i hadn't seen him maybe since then
and he was the first person that i just
very recently like hung out with in new
york outside with people walking around
it was not it was
surprisingly nice it was um yeah it felt
very like european we were out all the
restaurants have moved outside you know
and yeah they've shut down a lot of
streets and so chris and i just it was
it was so nice that we ended up i think
we were there for three hours just
having coffee
i bet that sounds lovely and just
appreciating the things that you taken
for granted before all this you know
like yeah just
being outside with people walking it was
really nice people seeing people yeah
enjoying a cup of coffee with a friend
you're like this is wonderful no how has
it been like what i've noticed like i
love what you did with your son early on
you were doing little like so sweet
little crafty things
with with right yeah that went away
quick
[Laughter]
that was me trying to be a really great
crafty mom and then i said you know what
here's a video game
let's try i've seen that in a couple of
months uh
i was like wow mullins really this is a
whole new
no i'm joking we do every day you know
that's actually been the toughest part
is
you know i i
i'm more of like um
the type of mother i am is
let's get out and go on an adventure or
do something i'm not like the crafty sit
at home and tinker and like come up with
really great science projects and stuff
like that it strikes me that that's
probably how your parents were raised
you guys yeah yeah adventures yeah
definitely no no likes we were never the
board game family or you know and i do
love all this stuff i just
it was never us you were active you were
doers
doers all the time always doing stuff um
what did your parents do
for a living my dad is um is still an
insurance broker okay
he has um built himself up to his own
company wow and my mom
um it changes every day depending on
who she feels like she's been her whole
life
that's so pretty she has mainly been a
fitness instructor and a waitress um but
she'll sometimes come to set and be in
their makeup trailer with me and she go
you know
i'm a makeup artist as well and i'll go
oh go
what
really she's worked like at the estee
lauder counter in sears you know for two
days
yeah i'm actually a chef a professional
chef
to the craft service people she's uh
she's she's done but she owned a health
food store for a while she's very
she's very good with nutrition and yeah
so she's i didn't know yogurt was white
until i was probably six or seven years
old i thought it was green because she'd
mix spirulina in with it oh my gosh i
had a lot of like questions when i
actually got out in the world oh my god
that's a funny way to be um isolated
in with with like nutrition does she
come to l.a often uh only like once a
year no she's getting to the point where
she wants to stay on home base but i'm
bummed because i want to meet her i'm so
curious to meet her lesson i will enjoy
i'll call you up next time she's
interested okay
well it's a trip i bet you were telling
me about her i can't believe i forgot a
survivor the last time i saw you um
everybody was like what she's going on
survival we were with we were with
the cast your cast from watchmen
oh yeah that's right yeah that's right
that's another fun night
oh my gosh we've had some good ones just
hey yeah
had you done stuff like that before that
was at a convention like um a horror
comic-con type thing yeah that was my
first time oh that's right
yeah probably
i'm not i'm not gonna partake in too
many of those no um yeah um but great
every now and then yeah well especially
ten years yeah yeah for the 20th
anniversary it's well now i can imagine
doing something like can you you know
yeah um it just it's too many people in
one place not gonna happen i'm wondering
how it's gonna be when we have you
worked since
this thing i haven't we're actually just
about to leave on monday
to go work for the first time i'm just
going for a week um to new mexico oh
i'm so excited and
you know we haven't been child free
since the lockdown so it's going to be
actually i say we not
like me as in we but me and my husband
yeah he's also in the phone
so we're going to go together cool which
i'm super excited about so i'm very
curious how it's going to be filming
sort of under coronavirus me too
i know i'm about to start i start on
monday something in atlanta i know i'm
uh
when you said you were doing press i
looked up um you're in like what are you
doing it for specifically because you're
in like four things now so there are
three things that are out right now um
there's and they all just happen to fall
into the same pocket which is amazing
like one of the films
it's called friendsgiving oh yeah like
two and a half years ago that's right i
remember you doing because i had a movie
at red hour my brother and i that we
were
doing they kept mentioning it uh they
were shooting it at that time and it i
was like yeah that that was a long time
so ben stiller produced this yeah well
nikki nikki weinstein myself and nikki
hi red hour produced it really and of
course ben but ben is so busy so he you
know we called each other a few times
it's so nice to come full circle from
heartbreak kid from heartbreaking yeah
which i first film ever did in in
hollywood it was yeah the first film in
hollywood yeah i didn't know that uh-huh
it went from um the comeback it was the
first job i got in hollywood on hbo with
lisa kudrow and then right after that
some doors opened up for auditions and i
got
the heartbreak kids oh wow marlon i
don't know why i just assumed
i don't know why that because that was
in the late 2000s like 2008 2000
that was even uh yeah maybe like 2000
yeah 2006 2007 maybe well the comeback
was something that people
love i can't tell you the number of
people who recommend that to me well
you've seen the comeback right and i
i still haven't which i'm embarrassed to
say
i guess not embarrassed enough to
rectify it how did you get that then
from so you had been living in sweden oh
do you mean the comeback yeah no i was
in canada oh right
i was in canada since i was two years
old um and i was there for 22 years and
then i got flown out here for an
audition
uh for a screen test actually from an
audition i did in canada for a movie
called the hot chick that rachel mcadams
ultimately got right i auditioned for
that too wait how do you say oh how did
you just say you got flown what um
for a flown
out
it was slight i just heard it
you do it's
i [ __ ] love canadians um where in
toronto you grew up in toronto yeah i
never even i remember i was bartending
in toronto at the age of like 1920. oh
my god and americans because drinking
age there in toronto is 19. oh that's
right i remember americans coming in and
i was thinking ah they sound so nasally
when they speak
to
now i live in america and i've been
working on my american and my canadian
friends come over i'm like wow they
sound like they've just gotten off the
farm yeah
oh that's really fun so crazy how your
perspective just shifts how does how
does the swedish accent fit is that just
does that even compare swedish is just
like martian language it's like a
completely different entity were you
learning english while you were when you
were a kid and were you in the so yeah
because we were we moved when i was two
right you know i was just learning to
speak so my family would speak swedish
with me at home and then
you meet kids and you just start you
know how easy it is for kids to like
communicate with language or without
they just play and then you kind of pick
it up along the way because you have no
accent you have no but you're obviously
still fluent
in swedish yeah i mean it's like at a
grade six sixth grade level oh
oh really um yeah so people are it's
my accent is fine but i see people
sometimes kind of first
and they're like she just
very slow how would you say oh poor dear
she seems a little slow in swedish
do you remember the last time we hung
out i maybe every time we hung out i
at least once make you speak speedy
swedish yes yeah you really do
yeah what did you guys think of the
swedish chef in the muppets hilarious
it's not far off
i mean it's a little more but swedish is
really sing-songy it is um yeah it
really is it's not
it's not romantic
um it's kind of silly and funny yeah
you know maybe that's why i make you say
it
and laugh every time yeah yeah it's very
offensive but are they offend i feel
like swedes are it's it would be very
difficult to offend the swede
yeah i don't think i don't think they're
offended i i couldn't um answer for this
right no you can't oh you can't speak
i had heard that there was um
i've known
swedish people i know
the ones i've known i'm not talking
about you but they've they've gotten
offended if i call them norwegian
or if i or there's a big there's a big
norwegian swedish thing right yeah
that's the thing and then definitely i
think finn's in norway then fans are
sort of their own
country because their language is
completely oh it looked like it's what
it's completely different i don't know
if i can swear on your show
you can't especially if it's in swedish
oh good well i did say that in english
but i'll say it how do you say [ __ ] in
swedish
there's not really there's no like
equivalence so if i mean what would you
say
like like
headset like
it's almost like you it's almost like
you transfer the sweet people do say the
f word in sweden
they do this so it looks um
[ __ ] up
what is there mon is there a word in
swedish that we don't have that like you
find yourself wanting to like ah i wish
we we had an english version of that
yeah there is there's a word and it's
logon and it's la gom
it's
it's it exists i mean it's two words
here it's just right like logom is like
it's not even just right it's like it's
not to this and it's not to this or to
that it's like somewhere in the middle
but it's it's logon
it's okay it's like it's okay it's
not quite okay i don't know how to yeah
because okay
because we'd have to say okay um
whether it's good okay or bad okay we'd
have to do that with tone
exactly and this is just a word you just
know what it means like neutral okay log
yes
that's really exciting so this is
exciting wait so you're in so you're in
toronto you're you're modeling at that
age right and you're in the punk band
where you were a lead singer
there's a lot oh boy i'm trying to i get
overwhelmed when there's too much to
unpack um
um
yeah okay i'll give you like a short a
snippet i mean modeling lasted for a
couple years um i started as a figure
skater for 10 years competed nationally
in canada i did not know that everything
no
i figured skated for a while i thought
that was going to be my future and then
um a couple years into high school i
just didn't want to get up before school
i was training to to be in the olympics
i mean that was my dream but then i had
met boys and parties and alcohol and i
was like i don't want to miss out on
that oh yeah that's all fun
it's all fun but i mean i miss my chance
to go to the olympics
have you ever talked to speedman about
that scott's no no why same thing yeah
he was um not a figure
but it's been awesome i know
i know uh oh i'm imagining him figure
skating uh a swimmer he's a he's a
swimmer he was like in the junior uh
in canada in um oh i didn't know that
that's cool see that's how modest
again i all i do is generalize about
canadians but uh that's how modest you
guys are how long have i known you and i
didn't know you were like close to going
to the olympics but how does that ever
come up like it's such a weird random
fact it's true you know it's not the
first thing that you lead with in
conversation hey did you know by the way
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv
the reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
i do remember when emmanuel when shriki
former guest of the show uh when she
introduced us she was like
i thought she was joking when she said
you were in a punk band are you in a
band you were the lead
fan you're a rock band um
because i was like
that's just not what you expect you know
and it was also the setting i think it
was the show tomorrow it was a very like
it was yeah yeah it was screaming like
that yeah it was fancy fancy she um
we're all dressed up
yeah and you were like that's usually
yeah but it's like that one thing where
you're like don't don't judge a book by
its cover and you also think think of
all the comedians that i'm sure you've
met along the way who are really
dark inside
you know what i mean like they're really
funny on the outside but wow do they
ever have stuff going on yeah yeah this
lightness that you see in front of you
it's real dark oh boy let's get let's
talk about that
you're too good of an actress to not
have any uh
of that but isn't that the nice thing
about acting you get to kind of
explore that explore it yeah yeah live
live sort of vicariously through a
character yeah i really miss it quite
cathartic you miss it yeah oh i can't
wait i do too i can't wait either what's
the thing in new mexico in santa fe it's
a vampire movie oh cool yes i have never
done that before and a friend of mine
wrote the script and called me up and
said you know do you want to ep on this
do you maybe want to do a role so i'm
just doing a little role
and then he knows my husband as well and
he's like i'd really loved it for jack
to be one of the leads and i was like
yeah i'm sure i mean this would be so
fun together jack looks like he could be
in a vamp like a kind of sexy like
vampire like kind of um
who was the guy in uh
one of those interview
[Music]
stuart townsend is he he's got a little
oh yeah yeah stewart townsend oh that's
so i'm going to tell jack he's going to
love you for life he looks like right
the funny thing is though justin is that
he's playing the complete opposition
scientist i'm i'm not even
this youtuber
so he dyed his hair kind of blonde and
like kind of like
surfacy and just you know doing the
whole like um influencer thing which you
know and he has to do an american accent
the complete opposite of what you think
but i be a vampire play like the old
vampire
jack is also in is he in friendsgiving
he's in friendsgiving yeah he looks
great in that but he's super funny in it
he really i mean he had um him and his
friends created a a stand-up uh no um an
improv group in england that was out on
i think it just it was all on youtube
it's called they're called the chuckle
dusters
um and they were hilarious and i mean
that's what he grew up with is the
improv stuff but he ended up getting
this he calls it a swords and sandals
show in england on the bbc did you meet
him on the show on on the swords oh we
met we've known each other for a few
years like we were acquaintances it's
actually my youngest sister's
fiance's friend from drama school in
england
tom
tom yes exactly so it's tom's friend so
jack would come into town every now and
like twice a year from england my sister
would call me up and be like hey tom's i
mean jack's in town do you mind if we
come and hang out i have pool here at my
house
yeah no but i wasn't even i wasn't even
interested he had a girlfriend oh no i
was interested in all the wrong i was
going through a divorce yeah um so i was
wild and going for all the wrong people
he even gave me advice i remember i had
gone to like
flown out to new york to be with someone
for new year's eve
and then when i got there this guy was
like um so i'm actually practicing um
celibacy at the moment
and i went are you kidding me and i
remember jack i telling jack this story
and he goes are you sure he didn't get
like an std or something and didn't want
to give it to you i was like oh my god i
didn't even think of that that was some
of the first conversations i had with
jack it's good advice
yeah it's uh
it concerns me a little bit that jack is
so astute when it comes to that
but um wow
i bet he's right
who knows i never found out i don't i
don't care to find out well he told you
this only after after you had flown all
the way to new york yeah
oh my god
i'm sorry but you know our relationship
is just physically based like that's it
so obviously i'm coming out to new york
for one thing and one thing only
i'm here in your house and you're saying
we can cuddle no
we can cuddle with boundaries
i
they're you know do you ever like hear
about um
a moment somebody had and just wish
immediately that you could like be there
for it just witness it that's one of
those moments i wish i could witness
your reaction oh god because you're so
nut you're so i'm sure you were like
i'm sure you weren't like what we were
supposed to no
of course not of course listen at the
same time i didn't think of anything i
was like fine he's going through
something i wish he would have told me
beforehand yeah for sure i probably
still would have gone out to be fair
because my best friend lives in new york
so like we all went out for new year's
and it was wonderful
but it was it was disappointing
yeah
that's so funny so he's but so he's
somebody that you're that's that's also
interesting that you're getting to know
him
um without that like uh separate from
any sort of
sexual stuff or you know
yeah and we got to know each other
really well the best all these crazy
stories of his girlfriends at the time
and my crazy escapades and
um that's so cool until i took a year
finally to
look inside like i was escaping from
this
situation yeah and i finally like two
years in i think
settled down and started going to
therapy and
self-love and you know taking courses on
meditation and really focusing on my son
and
and after that year
jack came back to visit again here and
he was no longer with his crazy
girlfriend
um and we had all gone out one night and
it was the first time we sort of sat
beside each other and really chatted and
i that's what i realized was like wow
but it still wasn't like a love at first
sight moment it was just like oh he's
really cute i mean yeah you just hey
yeah
yeah
and he hopefully he's not practicing
celibacy
no no no but he didn't work so well yeah
but it's like you see somebody clear
it's like you have a clarity about
everything i absolutely think that we
have journeys and and it doesn't mean
that we have to be with one person our
whole life
i still didn't say i don't say forever
to jack even now and i and i hope so but
one can only hope but i don't
i don't believe that that needs to be
true i think we should
be able to grow with each other as long
as we can and then when we stop growing
i think let's just call a spade a spade
and just thank each other for what we
had you know do you think that's
something that came from your family or
from your culture
no i think that's just years of um
introspective sort of trying to listen
to my own gut of what i really want and
who i am as a person which is still a
journey but
i know that for a fact i don't ever want
to beat myself up i think that
you know society in general has told us
what thing what relationship should look
like what love should look like and none
of it is true it can look like whatever
you want it to look like and it doesn't
have to be
marriage it doesn't have to be
it can be a relationship of three people
it can be two it can whatever you want
whatever works for you so you guys are
inviting i just want to make sure i
understand you're inviting a third
person in
uh yeah okay uh well we should start
recording
all right uh this has been life is short
uh
well i'm down i mean if you end up
opening opening i'll turn it up to a
third i'll have a conversation with jack
i'm sure you should probably you should
definitely run it by i think i'll start
there yeah yeah
um
at what point did you stop doing muse at
what point were you like that the music
thing are you doing it while you're
bartending in toronto
no the music thing was when i got out
here actually i never
had done music before and i came out
here to act
but i didn't get any acting jobs the
first year i was here and i happened to
meet these three italian
rockers
and they were looking for a lead singer
because they had such heavy accents
they're like
do you want to sing in the bend and i
was like uh i don't know how to sing and
go well i'll teach you this is no
problem it's no problem i think that's
what the joan chet said sure yeah
like who doesn't want to who doesn't
fantasize about being a rock star
nothing else was going for me so i was
like you know what why not i'll
i had to write the lyrics by the way
which i am not a writer if you listen to
the music it's terrible this is no
problem this is what the bobby dylan
said it's fine no you we write
all right
how many cultures can i offend wait what
um
is did you think was your first thought
like oh these guys are full of [ __ ] like
they're like hitting on me or
no no not at all they were actually i
know like their music was wonderful
they were actually brought out to
america by steve lukather who's in the
band toto oh wow um who really loved
them and so it wasn't like it was but
what happened was when they got out here
and they started recording stuff whoever
was recording them said listen man like
i'm just gonna be honest
to the lead guitarist singer he's like
your accent is just it's just way too
heavy like it and it really was and
bless him and he's a great singer and
all that but they just they're like you
need to find a front man or a front
woman or something and so oh my god
that's funny it just was like one of
those crazy things that i fell into
weird
i mean when an italian tell you they're
going to teach you how to sing
like our studio was a tiny little room
and the singing booth was the closet
in the closet trying to sing notes i've
never sung before in my life and i have
an italian yelling at me just saying it
i'm like well i am trying i'm trying to
sing it i don't know how to hit a note i
don't know how well what so that's what
i'm struggling with it's like did did
weren't you questioning like why me what
what do they see
in me
i know what they someone who spoke
english and could be like and could look
like a front runner you know what i mean
it's like a struggling actress desperate
and like well she's a she's a good
looking chick yeah
stuff for us and we'll give it a try you
know oh yeah we're all desperate justin
yeah that's no that's true that's true
but like without any wow so you are you
getting frustrated are you like
oh so we had so many fights i mean and
to be fair it wasn't like he just said
be the band he did he we i did go in and
like he kind of tested my voice out sort
of yeah he said yeah i can hear that
you're not a trained singer but i like
the sound of your voice and i will help
you i will help you uh help train you
yeah um but yeah so we did that for like
a good year and a half we wrote a whole
album and we
um did the whole la thing we did the
viper room we did the roxy you know
it was crazy so much fun i bet
were you
nervous on stage had you done
any performing on stage i liked theater
or anything never never i was so nervous
and that was one of the biggest things
that a guitar player would always get
mad at me he's like you have to speak
like in between songs you have to get
the crowd going i would just stand there
and smile
and wait for them to like get the key
right and under guitar for the next time
yeah
hi
okay uh we'll be right back with the
next song you know it's like what am i
doing oh my god who that
charisma though
[Laughter]
that once i started singing it was fine
yeah there's the in between i was really
shy as a as a teenager i don't think i
found my voice until i was maybe about
17. i barely
yeah i spoke
super shy
only hung out with the guys because i
didn't speak enough to like chitchat
with the girls so i just hung out with
my boys and let just let them take over
and
and sit and listen and eat french fries
that's so surprising to me i know i'm a
different person now you know how you
said you were like an outsider like a
yeah i just never really knew what to
say and i didn't um
girls are so talkative
and i just and i wasn't at the time and
so i felt
like it didn't have anything to offer
and and not that these are all the
stories that i made up in my head of
course yeah of course nervous too they
may have been intimidated by you
maybe
i mean but also not and i know people
say this but i was really i still at
like flat tested braces like there
wasn't much to be intimidated by a shy
you know i remember all the boys always
taught at high school you know it's
pretty shallow and the guys are like
look at her tits well i would not i'd do
her you know like that kind of stuff
that was a good impression of a teen of
a
teenage guy
look at her tits like doer
yeah
i know what you mean sort of i've
disappeared as much as i could but now i
have i couldn't imagine living in a
world without my close girlfriends
they're everything to me are your
friends then from toronto
so they're guys they're guys who are
still there
so yeah but i and i moved i was in
niagara on the lake for a while um
where i i gained a few really great
friends um girlfriends
and them i still have they're still my
best girlfriends um one of them actually
moved in with me when i was going
through my divorce and i just had my son
um
she moved in when my son was six months
old and stayed for a year and a half and
helped me raise my son
that's incredible one of my childhood
friends that i've known since i was 12.
oh my god do you think attempting to
perform on stage and then probably
getting better at it and more used to it
did that then
lead to your having the confidence to
pursue acting i liked acting already
from i mean i started in canada maybe
when i was 18.
oh
and i did and i did do tv commercials
and stuff funnily enough and
um but it was it it's like you're saying
you know you get to live vicariously and
you get to
be someone out going in with in a
character yeah so it was a great escape
for me um that's why i really loved it
is because i could be
sometimes who i wanted to be but it's
not the character but then you had all
the the meetings you know going into
meetings and i remember coming out here
with my one of my best girlfriends from
toronto and she was so brave and very
assertive and i really looked up to her
it was learning through watching and i
remember one day i had to walk into
a manager's office i was looking for a
manager and i just thought all right i'm
gonna do this the way laura would have
done it i walked in and i just pretended
to be confident and it worked so
interesting
yeah oh yeah well it's a cliche for a
reason i think it's that thing too
people say you know wake up and if
you're if you're sad or you have we all
have stories in our heads that we are
able to control and change if you're sad
wake up every morning and say thank you
in the mirror five times or tell
yourself you're beautiful five times and
you won't believe it at first but you do
it every single day and after a while
the synapses in your brain start to
happen
oh you train your it's like you can
train your emotional brain
exactly
oh is it mind over matter like um
yeah it's actually proven that um your
neuro
neurosynapsis like from your left your
right brain neurotransmitter
neurotransmitters maybe i don't know i
don't know this is the blind leading to
blood yeah exactly
but something in your brain actually
physically changes when you continually
push yourself to think differently but
you have to do it for a while in order
to change a pattern obviously oh that's
awesome
but yeah you it is it is really possible
and that's my mind over matter
you're a very good example of that and
you've obviously turned out
you're one of the best so uh this is a
good version of it but i wonder if there
are
i i wonder if there if this happens
where
somebody does a version of what you were
doing where they're i'm going to be i'm
going to be this person i mean i
remember trying to be cool and like on
meetings and like
i i i look back at some talk show early
talk show stuff and i it's so cringy
because i'm like there's there's nothing
more embarrassing than seeing somebody
who's not cool trying you know what i
mean that like totally trying to be cash
it's the worst but i wonder if people
then end up playing like really adopting
i mean we all know
those that's why those phony like
super actory whatever
yeah um yeah so i wonder if so i guess
it can go i you're right and i think
there needs to be it needs to be
go hand in hand with self work and
really ask yourself the real questions
of going
is this story that i'm telling myself
every day is it true usually it's the
opposite where if you're telling
yourself something negative that's what
you're trying to get rid of not by
replacing it with i'm [ __ ] awesome
going out with that you know it's like
what am i actually oh i'm a good person
i'm a nice person so let me leave with
that you know i don't i shouldn't i
think we're all
so hard on ourselves i'm sure we tell
ourselves
worse things that things that we never
dare say to anyone else you know what i
mean i think we're harshest on our own
on ourselves or at least i have been
throughout life yeah what about in
acting like were you
how were you when you did you that first
big movie when you did heartbreak kid
were you beating yourself up were you
i cried every single day for the first
week
get out of here oh yeah i called my
husband
at the time and who was the drummer from
the italian band
and i remember
every day after work crying going i
i don't know what i'm doing i shouldn't
be here
this is i i don't know how i fooled them
i just this i don't know what i'm doing
and oh my god little by little you know
it just got better and then ben stiller
was lovely and
just said a few nice things he didn't
know what i was going through but he did
say nice things and the fairly brothers
were lovely and they were complimentary
and i thought all right it's not i guess
it's not as bad as i think
and then and then i was so nervous
that's amazing what was the turning
point when when did you stop crying when
were you
when did you eat
yesterday
um
i think after that film it felt better
it was only that first week really that
was that was tough and then and then the
rest was just it was so much fun i had
such a good time
uh but it was the nerves that got the
better of me of course and just feeling
like a fish out of water and
really green
yeah yeah what makes sense i think that
it's crazy that that was your first
thing and then things just kept
spiraling afterwards yeah that was a
great door opener i guess more comedies
more romantic comedies i love all the
co-star roles you know because they're
always the craziest like 27 dresses they
get to be bridezilla and like you know
they're just
they're just so so much more fun
yeah totally you know everyone's always
looking for the leads and i'm going ah
they're always the most boring i totally
agree i know it seems like you're
producing a lot of things are you then
looking for
do you get to then say i imagine you get
to then pick these roles i i like to do
this as an actor so i can put myself
yeah i'm really enjoying it i think the
catalyst for me was when i tanya came
out the tiny harding oh so good margot
robbie it was so good but i was so
pissed and i called my age and i said
why wasn't i called in for this i i was
a figure skater for ten years oh my god
yes i was like i can't believe that this
did they didn't put it together and
that's when they said well margot robbie
actually she produced it and this was
her project and that's when the light
bulb went off and i went of course
that's exactly what i need to be doing i
have to [ __ ] margot robbie exactly
right oh wait what were you going to say
they're in time
yeah
wow that makes sense
so so i from then on i just i've been
working on you know i've optioned a
short story now by a new york times
bestseller that we're developing into
a series i've got a few different things
that i'm trying to put together from the
ground up that i really want to do
and then along the way to friends of
mine or people that i acquaintances that
i know now know that i want to produce
so
they've been coming to me with different
projects and
kind of choosing the projects that i
think i can do something with or help
put them put it together what about
directing something mom i would love to
but i still think i need a couple more
years i only see that because it's so
all-consuming and my son is only seven
and i wanna be there for him so i think
it's more about that that i just
i see the toll it takes on directors
and i think a few more years and i'll
maybe dip my toes in just a little bit
[Music]
okay these are gonna be just quick i'm
so sorry i know we're a little past time
uh just quick like lightning round okay
molly do you use uh emojis a lot are you
like a big emoji person i use them i use
them what would you say is your go-to
what's like the like the first stop in
your arsenal the one that's like this
uh-huh oh she's putting her hands up
like yay it's almost like but it's not
yay but it's like i know what you mean
it's a little blushy a little blushy and
two hands up by the face i don't know
what that emoji is but it's really cute
we maybe there's a swedish word for it
[Music]
what is it no joking
oh yeah
no it's too positive for logan it is
it's much more positive it's just kind
of like but at the same time it's almost
like it feels a little bit canadian
because it's like i'm sorry and thank
you and i'm happy and i hope you're okay
with it yes yes that's what i love about
it that it would be so that i'm
surprised i don't use that one it really
would that because i'm often trying to
express that
oh well there you go now you found one
yeah my mind is i combine the um the
kind of look the down cast but positive
like
smiling but like this like hmm oh really
with a with a like oh like sorry oh the
one that's just yeah it's just like
sorry yeah so nice you don't want to
ruffle any feathers if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play um and why i'd probably like to
be a slalom skier
and i hate winter and i hate cold but i
think i love the feeling of like the
idea of being able to go down that fast
i'm a speed freak and that just feels
like such freedom yeah
yeah do you are you a good skier or like
i do ski yeah i do see i used to be a
really great confident skier now it's
like it's a few years past in between
trips so
uh wow slalom skier that'd be cool and
you're not afraid of stuff like you're
not like
i i guess figure skating is so there's
something
so dangerous about that and if you if
during your formative years you do that
i guess i don't know i never sound as
dangerous but it's just
um
of course you can get hurt because when
you fall on ice it doesn't hurt it
doesn't it does hurt yeah it sprained my
tailbone twice it was terrible oh god
that must have hurt like that was
terrible i couldn't sit for two weeks oh
man
but it was it was it there's
i i love
the sound of when
um the zamboni has gone off and just
cleaned the whole rink and you're the
first person on the ice and you just
hear your blades oh you're cutting
it's cutting the ice
and you go as fast as you can it's like
you're flying wow
i bet and i also probably helped with
any sort of performance
anxiety i mean yeah i mean you're out
there on your own with your music and
your skates that's it
oh god right and you i i don't know why
i'm so hung up on anxiety but uh you you
that never gave you
of course you get nervous and before a
competition always oh it nerves but i
think that only helps if you have nerves
i remember once i did i did you have a
routine obviously but i forgot my
routine halfway through oh
it was terrible and just kept going and
made up a shitty routine got last place
it was it was awful but um my coach was
furious oh god did you have one of those
for so long you know oh
lovely but and she was really loved but
i could tell
she was just more disappointed that's
the worst yep
yeah the disappointment oh
yeah um and i know that feeling i
remember playing the violin when i was a
kid and
i once got
i don't know if this compares but like i
got lost i got lost in the song and same
things it's a thing that you go
you take lessons and you
practice so long and then you miss one i
remember missing a note and then i
thought about that note and i tried to
play it again and then i just started
i i bet mine might have been more
embarrassing because i started making up
i was playing like a mozart and then i
just started who's a genius and
obviously and i just started like
making up my own
[ __ ] thank god
that blood the feeling of like blood
rushing to your face you know yeah it's
terrible it's a terrible feeling
um
it's a nice thing about movies
yeah take two you can do take five if
you need yeah yeah speaking of laughing
in a movie uh was wandering did you guys
break a lot and wanderlust
oh god yeah
i had we had there was one scene with
paul rudd that i had to do and we were
sat on the bed and he was trying to like
he was basically in his in his way
wanted to say like let's get it on but
he
kept stumbling as his character was
meant to do
and i just remembered judd apatow was on
set that day
and he was like just throwing things out
at us and i was laughing so hard and the
camera was behind me and you can see my
shoulders going
you just kept saying
keep it together it's like i'm trying
i'm trying
and then he's shouting out lines for us
to say and then all of a sudden he goes
time is money and i was like okay okay
time is money and he's like no
it's not a line
time is money stop laughing i mean it
got to the point where he was just like
oh he was like genuinely yeah wow
um but i couldn't it was yeah just it
was a it was one of the funniest movies
to shoot i bet i bet that stuff with
paul at the end in the mirror is like oh
it's brilliant
what he's talking about his dick oh and
that's what kind of stuff he was doing
to my face
i can't nobody can yeah no
the only time i can hold it in um when
it's something like that is is is if
like somebody like judd was like hey
that's that would there you go break me
yeah yeah
um
or if the other person were like come on
you know i've had that too where it's
like somebody i really admire is like
hey dude yeah or you look around at the
crew and they're like we'd really like
to go home to our kids yeah yes that's
the worst that's oh god yeah i locked it
up right away yeah yeah
it's just like yeah you know what you're
like i've had that that's the worst
feeling when you're like terrible you're
laughing and you look around oh i know
that feeling
and you know nobody nobody care nobody
finds it funny
i get it i get that nobody finds it
funny i'm trying hard but then it's like
oh it's like farting in church where
it's like funnier because you're not
it's you're not supposed to do it yeah
you were race buddhist by the way
why am i telling you that yeah thank you
for reminding me yeah amazing um my mom
practiced it for a while it was the
japanese um branch of it called nishin
goju
and we used to go to temple um once a
week and i loved it i just loved the
philosophy growing up with that i don't
practice it anymore it's i mean it's
something that i love but
was it very nature-centric like it's
very yeah it's just sort of
you know creating good energy it's karma
isn't it it's yeah you know do it's
there's similar messages it's just be
good and create good energy around you
and that's what the chanting is it's
like bringing you back into your body
and getting grounded so that you can be
there for others and so you can be
present and
um it's so interesting because my son
where we don't have any sort of
religious denomination at all
um but i've been raised buddhist and
we we've talked about sort of of course
it's come up and my son one day went
mom you know that god is real right oh
what what makes you say that and he goes
oh cause because i've seen him i was
like oh you know you have have you and
he goes yeah
actually he's sitting on that lamppost
right there we were in the car me jack
and and sebastian and especially this
yeah he's sitting on the lamppost and i
go oh and what is he what is he saying
anything and he goes yeah yeah actually
he thinks that you and jack should buy
me um suction cup hands and shoes or
else he might kill you
it's like you're using god as a bribery
right now
the first time you mentioned god that's
what it was a surprise to buy him
something that he wanted but he had
actually heard about god in school and
then yeah talked about and i said you
know everyone believes in different
things you know something he's all
powerful
yeah and i was like you can believe
whatever you want this is what i believe
i believe in
this and then like you know and there
might be you know reincarnation and da
da so now he believes in all of it he
believes in god and the big bang theory
and in reincarnation and in karma why
not
yeah sure he believes in whoever's gonna
get him a suction cup uh pan thing
that's so funny yeah it's so funny um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be
nutella oh yeah just nutella buy the
spoon you say nutella
nutella is that the proper
nutella what do you say yeah
i thought it was nut i say nutella oh no
oh
no you would know i think it's i don't
know it's a german it's german or
italian now i can't remember now that
you say it but i i first discovered it
or was introduced to it in europe
nutella and you can't get enough of it
no i really can't like if it's in the
house i have to because i love it when
it's gooey and so i'll eat it like it's
cereal
with a spoon just straight oh yeah with
a spoon you don't want to eat it with
anything else it's like my ice cream but
i get i get so sick i make myself sick
that i can't stop it's actually my
addiction so i have to put it in the
freezer because i don't like it when
it's cold and you can't
smart yeah then i know i have it in the
house only for my son to have it with
pancakes on sundays we make pink nutella
but during the week it's frozen in the
freezer
so you tend to it to like keep yourself
from it yeah
wow yeah god you know that's been a long
time since i've i like it in cra uh
crepes crepes
yeah huh
um there was something with nutella
nutella recently that it was i shouldn't
tell you this probably because it was
what is it it's it's something bad right
it's all like it's 90 palm oil and then
right
three nuts and some cacao
it's all crap
right sorry that's okay
that's how much you love it yeah i do
yeah wow um
what's your favorite movie of all time
this is a tough one i mean a movie that
you were looking forward to showing your
son
that was very special i mean that's hard
too um well
i mean that kind of stuff is all the the
classics like yeah like princess bride
and back to yeah and those kind of
things i can't wait to show him um i
keep trying to convince him to watch
back to the future with me but he's not
into i show him the trailer he's like
none no i'm not interested
molly this is like a legitimate
fear of mine about having kids like i'm
so fr like i'd love to have kids i love
kids but um i'm so afraid that i will sh
i will that will happen and they'll be
like meh
i know you know and i'll get like angry
with i'll get like personal i might stop
loving them i don't i don't think so
justin i think you're too sweet
yeah disappointment when he's like i'm
like you're seven now we can watch this
yeah but he's not he's not i guess he's
not ready yet but oh my god that's
exactly how old we were
were we seven around that time yeah
we're the same age and um
it came out in 85.
oh wow yeah you're right yeah then
that's when i watched them for sure
when they came out
that was what we had back then you know
what i mean now they have other options
so
they watch
anyway but
my fate one of my favorite movies is no
country for old men oh yeah
you know this is well now speaking of
shaming people for not
appreciating something i've never seen
it
i know
it's really good
i think i've i think this has happened
to us before
uh you're surprised i haven't seen that
wait this stuff you were saying the
stuff he watches is crap it's like tick
tock stuff it's no i don't i don't allow
much oh
he's seen it a couple times and he would
love to but we're really really cute did
you watch the social dilemma
no no i'm dying to see that you watch
that and you'll see why you don't want
your kids on social media and it was
even before that it's just social media
is not great for their brains and i do
you know we try to keep them off as much
as possible he's only allowed video
games on the weekends for two hours and
that's it wow good for you because it's
just it just fries your brain man oh no
i get it but that must be hard to
enforce it is it's really hard because
that means you have to do more hands-on
and uh
hence the no directing yeah yes yeah
hey marlon what do you call the circle
over the a in your name
so you don't call it anything it's just
it's a letter it's called
oh that's why it's
my name
no i'm laughing because every time i
hear someone else speak swedish i hear
how ridiculous
um if you could live uh if you had to
live somewhere else where would it be
africa
oh yeah
anywhere in particular where i mean i
still have so many countries to explore
in africa but yeah i've been to four
different countries there i love all of
them um
dover to joburg
uh
nairobi um
uh
zanzibar which is more of a vacation
place which is amazing
where is zanzibar what country zanzibar
is an island on the coast on the
east coast i think i hope i'm not
mistaken no but
um we were definitely up by tanzania
when we went out that's east yeah yeah
okay
it's beautiful it's wow gorgeous but
that is really like it feels more like a
resort place like you go for a real
vacation
yeah i was able to actually experience
the culture and the people and i was
there for six weeks and it was
incredible wow oh i'd love to go
um
there's a different feeling there and
like these the earth is red in certain
parts like you're on mars and you have
these animals everywhere that are
beautiful you know it's just
incredible
uh if you have dinner with three people
dead or alive whom you've never met who
would they be oh um
tilda swinton uh michelle obama uh-huh
and
why you think why tilda swinton what
what about her just her she's so
fascinating i've just listen i think
she's an amazing actress i just know
from news articles or interviews that
she lives a quite unique life very open
her philosophy on
love and yeah exactly and so i'm so
curious as to
how that works and you know
how well we're going to find out when i
become your third
oh and you you said people i haven't met
otherwise you would have been the first
oh yeah thanks that was a trick question
um
yeah she does seem really cool really
interesting right yeah i think she'd be
really interesting to sit with and very
with real convictions she has somebody
who has such a different
outlook like that and mindset but is
very convicted about it you know yeah
it's kind of rare
um
and i yeah i don't know who the third
person is i'm trying to think if there's
someone i love to watch ted talks yeah
and there's always i would love to have
someone
who's just lived through something
extraordinary come and sit at the table
you know what i mean just to pick their
brain
no no that's good i'm going to send you
one
one that really i keep thinking about
really inspired me okay oh i'd love that
um who who's your favorite muppet
did you
i love that question did you grow up
with them
i grew up with them but i was more of a
fraggle rock oh oh okay yeah red so yeah
it would probably be one of the things
yeah okay i love fragrance um
who who uh if you had to be one age
physically for the rest of your life if
you were a vampire and you were like i
want this i want to beat this physically
somewhere in my 20 like mid-20s yeah
that's like the perfect
age where nothing nothing ever changes
yeah
oh my god
remember those
i remember you know but
not necessarily
good i mean i remember drinking during
those days and like the next day was
like i i look at some movies now that i
did then i was like oh i remember going
out like the night before i mean i was
so undisciplined and um you get away
with it i wouldn't want to mentally no
no
basically just your metabolism
um if you could be reincarnated uh as an
animal some sort of animal oh um
probably an eagle oh yeah i think an
eagle would be really lovely i think
they're beautiful i'd be able i want to
fly yeah that would be a dream so an
eagle or an owl but i think an eagle
might be really cool they live a long
time and they're they're the only
monogamous um bird ah that's very
non-tilda swinton i know
well i'm going to think differently now
when i see i have a place in
massachusetts um you guys have to come
one day uh but there's he love it it's
on a lake and there's there's an eagles
nest on this little island and um so i
see them the he i see i'm right
underneath his hunting path and uh so
you'll see him swoop down and pick up
fish but they have they have very a very
high pitched
like a screech
you know it's not like
what
i always thought
no no i thought it was interesting
because like an ego you think would be
like i don't know what it shouldn't
sound like oh it shouldn't be like uh i
don't know what i thought it'd sound
like but it's like
i will know i'll sound like an opera
singer
i'll know it's you how you know it's me
yeah
um
what a delicious looking fish
if you um would you rather be called an
attractive or unfunny oh unattractive
yeah
um yeah
be terrible to be unfunny i don't think
i'm super funny as a person in real life
but i just i would rather be funny than
attractive for sure you don't think
you're funny i'm not like quick like
some people are you know like people
some people are just go go go go i'm not
saying i'm not funny i mean i can have
fun but i'm not the gal who's gonna tell
you a joke and nail it at all
there are people who way better at that
[ __ ] than i am i'll be your best wingman
you say something funny and i'll i'll
help you keep it going that's the best
ideas yeah yeah well see those funny
people that gravitate toward you they're
probably also a little narcissistic so
they're like well i don't want her yeah
it's perfect
it works um which did did you get the
golden girls in toronto was that a show
that you i was i was there i just i
never was um i i love them there's no
reason i just never got in yeah um there
so cross off the next question do you
prefer dogs or cats
dogs we have a little dog
a little like a chihuahua i just love
them no she's a little much little jack
russell kind of mother and she's oh
they're just so full of personality
yeah uh the beatles for the rolling
stones do you prefer rolling stones
really
interesting
yeah i mean i appreciate the beauty of
course they've got some great of course
amazing music but the rolling stones
just they rock a little bit it's funny
rock people who have have a rock
background any sort of music background
often say
they often answer the rolling stones um
what is your song
it's just more fun to
it's more fun to it would be more fun to
play yeah
yeah
have you seen them play
i have a long time ago actually in
toronto i saw them and that was i was in
my 20s um and went to see them and it
was just
it's incredible
it was a two-hour show
it was full on like how and he was
probably in his late 60s
apparently my brother uh
dated a ballerina uh she was in like one
of the best ballerinas in um the
national i forget whatever it doesn't
matter she was a great ballerina and and
he was married to he was dating at the
time one of the other ballerinas mick
jagger
and he would come afterwards and just
like watch them you know he would come
to pick her up from these rehearsals
and every once in a while he'd get on
the piano and
and uh
and my brother be like well did you
stick around to watch no
i was like why would you want
oh he's right there and he was very kind
of like
deferential to their space and do you
mind if i play but you know
yeah how cool and but apparently he used
to work out all day um to to maintain
uh
um well thanks for doing this
of course love we'll see you soon all
right big big squeeze
[Music]
well
that
happened so that just happened that just
happens
she has a little bit of a tom kavanagh
at with her elves
yes she does yeah i
yes well she reminds me a lot of her
right it really makes sense that they're
close i know you should see them
together they get even more effusive and
affectionate and warm when they're
together if you can imagine and they
both
uh paula guccino too is like that she'd
be a good guest on the show she would be
yeah
the way she says your name there's
something so warm and inviting about it
you know it's actually really oh justin
yes yes it reminded me of emmanuel
shriki the way she when she addresses
you it feels like a hug just hearing
your name yeah you know i was smiling so
much and it's so hard not to smile
around her she's got such an inviting
everything yeah there's like she's very
measured and kind and warm but
she's also kind of salty oh it's a
combination it's a great combination
it's the best because without the
saltiness yes it could potentially
become a little not saccharine just a
little like tame yeah a little soft a
little boring but to add that warmth and
kindness and then you you mix in a
little spiciness swedish bite yeah game
over she's a winner
she's a winner her mom sounds like a
winner i know i was surprised when she
told me that thing about survivor i was
so she's one of those people in my life
where
um you know you go through the
you do the recap of the last couple of
years and it's like but you pick up
right away i i
i just have so much um affection for her
and whenever i see her i learn something
at least a couple things that are
impressive about her that i like about
her there's something very evolved about
her yeah you know and i think
she's done so many things in her life
she was talking about being a figure
skater and like a really competitive
figure i just learned this i like how
you compared your violin recital to uh
for like high stakes you're like oh i
can totally relate to that well just in
the sense that my hand got a little
sweaty during a violin recital when i
was seven just in the sense that like
it's all relative you know like freshers
pressure right and
yeah it wasn't like a international
stage but it was the pequot library in
southport connecticut i got and for me
that was um you know it's like going to
tell the this girl in high school oh you
don't just tell me on it those those
recitals were terrified oh the pressure
i terrified you remember the smell of
what was that ivy have you been into the
library in the last like 15 20 years yes
you know why do you smell that smell oh
it's like it brings you back to that
fear
as a kid
like it's like being in a doctor's
office office and smelling that tongue
depressor and the rubbing alcohol yeah
and going right back to like that fear
of being getting shocked i wasn't that
scared of the doctor as a kid like you
were i didn't mind getting shot [ __ ]
hated it i hate it but yeah that library
where we had these recitals and i
sometimes once in a while i think like
you both have to get scared at childhood
recitals
like that's mahogany smell remember it
was very like old smelling and mildewy
and yes god in heaven is that evocative
but uh but yeah malin the fact that she
just
i just learned about her i've known her
for 15. she's done a lot of stuff done a
lot that she was wanted to be uh
a psychologist
thing i didn't know that she was a model
she had she was the lead singer of a
band like she's done so many had such a
forrest gumpy kind of life yeah that uh
it it it does
make sense that she is evolved
as a person oh my god she's done so many
things i experienced so much she's lived
out even like her whole ethos about uh
roman love and that she doesn't want to
stay forever that to me is so really
like mature and evolved practical but a
little sad well smart also in her case
very european she's gone through a
divorce
so yeah in her reaction in her reality
marriages don't always last forever
exactly
well over 50 of marriages end in divorce
i know so
there is something somewhat foolish
about being so sure that it's gonna last
forever
but there's also something sad about
admitting that it might not you know
well i'm torn on the issue well i'd like
to think it would i think i might be
biased too because
i'm sure there's a part of me like to
think you know maybe it won't last
forever and she will
move on with another
person
you know like you well or anybody uh-huh
let's not you know nail that door shut
up you did at two separate occasions
volunteer to be the third member of
their uh romantic relationship i would
do it i would do it and the second time
you said it ingest mostly mostly um she
it was a call back to when you said it
before and she thought you were talking
about until i did a dinner guest as a
dinner guest oh i could tell you were
referring to you're like now that i'll
be oh she did the third person and she
was like oh yeah you'd be good on the
dinner she like oh she completely
misunderstood what you're saying
thankfully yeah i feel so comfortable to
like just tell her about that stuff and
i'm sure her husband is the same way i
was surprised by how nervous she was
when
she was making a heartbreak kid because
i was too
i've just
knowing her a little bit and seeing how
breezy and confident she is and how good
she is in that movie
um i never would have guessed you never
would have guessed i know and so every
night she'd come home crying because she
felt like she was screwing it up and i
know it's such a fearless person it's
such a good example of
never you never know what something's
going through you can never tell
what's going on with someone just by
like a performance i know for example
she had i'm thinking about some of those
like there's a oh sorry there's like a
pretty graphic
set it's not scratch it's like there's
like a sexy like a funny sex scene in
that and i like that movie i think
that's a really underrated movie yeah
brothers still looks great in it um
it's got a lot of funny uh
support supporting characters uh
yeah me too i i won't re-watch it but i
do remember that sex scene there's she
does stuff in it that like and and very
like vanity-free you know when she like
breaks out in those hives yes and she's
like hey she starts it's a very it's a
very confident performance yeah which
again she's like unhinged makes the fact
that she was insecure while making it
very surprising you know what she's i've
always thought she did so well so it's
seemingly effortlessly and without any
as it turns out i was wrong without any
kind of uh second guessing ever she just
seems like she has instant chemistry
with whoever she's acting opposite you
know yeah like i thought that about
watchman her stuff with um
was it patrick wilson
and it's um
it's really like intense it's you can
the tension that they have is really
palpable
it is and and uh it couples retreat too
like sometimes with scripts that um
you know it's not necessarily there on
the
on the page and she just brings so much
on the page
that's a very difficult thing to say she
loves nutella and she pronounces it
nutella ah yeah i pronounce it nutella
too
and not from now on i might i'm gonna
because i
i really you've had it right oh yeah
yeah of course i've had it mostly in
in like crepes remember that that great
place in the farmer's market in l.a yes
that was really really good i'm not into
sweet crepes oh you're not
but i hope she's not listening anymore
really nutella is really big in
in europe and germany they do a lot for
breakfast they have a lot of little
things they eat it with every other has
a condiment right yeah it's very popular
you don't want nutella
you're going to have your salad sandwich
without the nutella but now that you're
saying nutella that sounds right well
i'm sure she's right about it because i
think they know they're more uh nutella
nutella yeah they're i think nut
nut
i think she's probably right because
they are more into that uh over there
although she grew up in ontario i kept
making that mistake i mean she was two
when she moved over here oh canada and
sweden
look if you ever
questioned my
reverence for canadians and swedes just
look at
mollin's the i mean she's also i don't
think they're all like no i know they
couldn't be i think even though all the
sweets i've met so far are kind of a
version of her i know they're like great
and like fun and warm yeah i know
and good looking i you don't have to
sell me i know sweets
crazy you haven't been to sweden it
really is i'm dying to go you're not
allowed to say i'm dying to go because
you're 42 and you have the means to do
it not now like you just said uh you
also said to her i'm dying to see the
social network you're not i know that's
true that's true
you can see it that's a mom it's been
available to you for like a month it's
so much easier for me to see the social
network oh i've been going to sweden
that's true i'm dying to see it i know
what what a drama you're not dying
whenever i hear people talk about it i
think oh i should see that movie uh but
nine ninety-nine percent of the time
i've completely forgotten about you know
sometimes then this might that's true i
get so excited talking to mullen i i
like i feel so
positive and
kind of energized is the word um
that
i think maybe i just got a little
carried i get a little carried away with
my hyperbole
oh that's the best or
oh my god i'm dying to do that yes
you're also
a pretty hyperbolic person in general
hyperbole
let's read a letter let's read a letter
okay okay
this is a letter from
uh miranda c
subject mind blowing would you rather
hello long brothers i'm a 25 year old
from pa i'm a long time listener and
love this podcast because i have a
sister who's four years younger than me
well thanks miranda i like that name
miranda me too but then it must be
annoying to be like oh are you a miranda
from sex yeah that's what i think the
way you and christian carry on together
reminds me of how my sister and i get
along and sometimes don't there there
were two movies in particular that we
agreed define our childhood those movies
are mystery men ah starring ben stiller
good movie yeah inappropriate and galaxy
quest many exclamation points yes really
she said
these are two movies we watched over and
over again and we had friends over and
hosted movie nights and showed it to
friends that's so cool and had themed
parties and costumes from wow we can
recite galaxy quest verbatim and we
reference it all of the time she's
underlined wow
justin it must be pretty cool for you to
know that a character that you played is
a staple of nostalgia and fun childhood
memories for strangers that you'll never
meet that is really cool miranda really
cool
i immediately associate you with my
childhood which i imagine can either
come off as very weird and creepy no or
very heartfelt and wholesome
hopefully the latter no the only thing
remotely negative about that is that
there's a
there's a part of me that feels a little
old
and mostly it's just really nice also
we're a couple of latina ladies ah so
the recent episode with asa
uh aisa was super fun for us to listen
to and hear about
isa asa
we're super fun i wonder if she's
listening yeah i don't think so
hey asa if you're listening uh just text
me banana the word banana yeah yeah or
the emoji
uh it was super fun for us to listen to
and hear about her personal experience
with the conundrum of needing to work
but not wanting to be repeatedly
typecast into one of the traditional
latina lady tropes my sister and i have
had a would you rather question for
years that we fundamentally disagree on
oh yeah i'm excited and we like to pose
to other people at parties when things
start to get philosophical in the wee
hours of the night i have an idea of
what you two will say and of course you
will both agree
but i'm curious
i know who wrote this but i'm curious to
hear which side you take i hope it's not
too crazy or mind [ __ ] wow i'm excited
yeah i've never heard that as a i like
that mine [ __ ]
would you rather it's like would you
rather eat swedish fish or
yeah sour patch yeah would you rather
let you
i feel like one of the early ones was
peanut m ms and they used to be more
like peanut m ms is the one candy you
gotta pick that's what you say over
anything yeah it's it's the most
complete single candy you can you can
buy i'm getting back into kitkats uh we
have we got those couple months ago for
halloween yeah the um
the marshmallow kitkats
pretty interesting is that what we have
yeah those are marshmallow i couldn't
put my finger on marshmallow
oh you thought they were white chocolate
i did but then they have a little green
in them yeah halloween themed they were
like
goblins
all right hey uh would you rather go
anywhere in the world
this is a limitless ability to travel
anywhere without needing to go through
airports buy tickets etc imagine beam me
up technology you can go anywhere
instantaneously but you no longer
experience time
no one but one other person can
accompany you throughout your travels to
any place in the world
okay so you get to bring a friend that's
cool or
okay so there's that and you live
forever there's no time once you start
traveling you can go anywhere
instantaneously but you no longer
experience wouldn't go anywhere
instantaneously but you no longer
experience time i guess so okay does
life not move forward do do things so
how could you experience a place if it's
not moving if it's not in motion and
well what's the second one second one is
you can travel through time
to any point in history in the past or
in the future as distant in time as you
want to go for as long as you want but
you are confined to one physical place
of your choosing for example if you
choose that the house where you grew up
uh and can see who lived there that'd be
weird who lived there before you like
that would be so weird like watching a
movie you want i just got chills you
won't interfere or alter the time
continuum
and you can witness what will happen
hundreds of years from now to that
particular place
but you can't travel anywhere else
outside of that area you've chosen um
and then she says uh tldr what's that
stand for i've seen that that's uh
it's like an internet acronym um i think
it means
like
two uh two uh
two uh too long
didn't read oh like just it's a it's a
way of summing things up too long don't
read but well here's what it is when
you're limited to only one would you
prefer the unlimited
oh oh oh if that was just it up yeah
when you're limited to only one would
you prefer the unlimited freedom to
travel throughout time
or throughout physical space on earth i
see so so it must be that time is paused
that time stops okay uh for me it's
pretty easy um what about for you
um
[Music]
i for me it is you could do it uh can
you have a friend in the time travel one
ah let's say you can
let's say you can let's say you could
have a friend in both
well the other one is the first one is
dark for me because you if time i'm hung
up on the time stopping thing
you know don't
don't get hung up on that let's just
think of it more as you can go anywhere
in the present and i would do that and
or you can go to any time period in that
one spot i think that's more what it is
yeah
and if and if that's the case i would
100
go anywhere in the present mm-hmm
because the idea of first of all the
same spot what spot do you pick exactly
that's the problem let's say you pick
your child at home that's what i was
thinking um it would be nice obviously
obviously to like go back could be
horrifying it could be horrifying and
also
the future could be really horrifying
more so
and the past could be horrifying or
boring like yeah the the spot of land
where our house was 300 years in 1920
before it was built and then it's like
okay it's mostly it'd be like
you know at that point back to the
future i lie always as far as the eye
can see yeah yeah the twin point uh old
man peabody um
yeah so but when he goes to um where his
where that uh that that housing
community is being built where that like
neighborhood is going to be like that
yeah yeah uh what's it called a lion
oh yeah that's right and they just put
up the two lines and it's like down and
pans back to like that is so cool but i
think about that like um
you know you know even going back to
rochester where our parents grew up and
seeing paws house
um the last time we went back there i
don't know if you remember this
there was so much development in that
area i just it i had a version of that
experience where it was like oh my god
the last time i saw this it was just
like a field it was just fields have you
experienced that with a place where like
you that next time you go back like 10
years later or something it's like like
riverfield where we went to elementary
yeah it's a little bit all it's all
developed now
houses yeah
yeah i think in general also i spend too
much
time in my brain
thinking about like kind of dwelling on
the past
being afraid of the future me too and i
don't like a goal from a goal of mine is
to
live more in the present in general yeah
so
um so this particular hypothetical
this like you could go anywhere in the
past or future it
it's just not something i want to uh
encourage in my own brain like i would
much rather
experience the present in all sorts of
like cool like when jerry was talking
about
uh being in africa and like i would like
to know africa here's sweden
i would love to i am
more of the world in the present counter
argument if you were to do this one spot
any point in time thing
then you could have the experience of so
many different time periods which really
would be fascinating it would be cool to
see
our house of course and like in the
future it'd be cool to have that i don't
think that's it for your life i think
it's just you have this ability to do it
in one spot you could still go to sweden
you could still go to japan it's just
like time doesn't stop i guess i think i
instantaneously travel that'd be amazing
amazing yeah no lines no what's the
thing that you think of first when you
think about the e if you could travel
with that kind of ease like what's the
thing that you think oh my god i'd be
able to do this
oh see i think more
this i wouldn't have to do this oh no i
know i know like once you take my shoes
off and like
walk gross where everyone's been walking
through the uh oh i just met my sector i
guess what i'm getting at is like i
thought about just food like getting to
like oh you want to try the best soup
dumplings like taiwan like that go to
taiwan oh yeah it is so cool it's it's
like do i want to live an incredible
life in the present or
see a bunch of [ __ ] that came before me
and after me
it's like one of them is living and one
of them is spying you know yeah that's
true you're like a um you have actually
once like voyeuristic and one is you're
like an anthropologist who has like a
really cool tool right
yeah that's true i don't even know if i
if given the choice of having that
ability i don't know if i'd take it well
something really terrifying about i know
i don't think i'd like to see just like
if you go back to the 50s in our house i
don't want to see
people live existing in that space and
calling it their home i don't either
or in the future a family like that well
i think
it would be a mistake to pick if i if i
had to pick one spot i would go with our
home i wouldn't pick our house yeah what
would you pick uh that's a good question
um one spot you could uh
that's really tough that that is a
really good question so because anywhere
in america it's like you wouldn't really
be able to go back that far
was like unt untamed like um london
maybe maybe but like
london
200 years ago was really yeah how do you
be dark i mean unless it's like booking
him palace but then that'd be depressing
it's like oh what rich [ __ ] like can
happen in this house now i don't want to
travel in time yeah i just want to live
more in the present yeah well thanks
miranda good question yeah really good
question and um then she says thanks for
reading this far
smiley face old-fashioned smiley face
thank you so much for your podcast and
your contributions to the world wow
that's nice so nice take care
she says sincerely
short sisters miranda and sophia c
well thanks short sisters from the long
brothers that was a great that was
really good i'm gonna be thinking about
that one for a while yeah that was good
a huge huge thank you to malin
you're like melancholy that this is over
yeah i am it's how i feel when i'm done
hanging out with her i got sad at the
end of the interview but you shouldn't
be sad you know why because it's the
holidays no i know and i'm like very
lucky i'm lucky to know someone like me
exactly
i'm lucky to know you i'm lucky to have
read that letter from miranda and if you
would like to write into the show our
email address is life is short at
wondery.com
merry season merry season happy holidays
happy holidays
and uh thanks for listening we'll talk
to you soon next week in fact right of
course
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by one
megan monaco see your producer is
michelle mieshlands
an audio engineer on this one is sergio
enriquez two gentlemen get their hands
on the executive producer job marshall
louie another one is ernan lopez for a
company someone named wanderate jingle
jingle happy holidays
[Music]
oh there's a word that you guys probably
don't have in your in your lexicon
parking twerking yeah
oh you have that's what miley cyrus
did yeah she did it once well she
probably did it more than once now what
is it how would you describe it
okay twerking it's like moving sexually
but staying in place
yeah kind of
yeah it's like anyway that's a great
script that's a pretty good description
yeah
yeah like if it were a crossword puzzle
oh sorry
static sexual movement
oh that's not a bad
definition right how would you describe
it with your hips i think you might have
to clarify that it's it's the butt it's
the butt that moves like it's like this
oh my god
you're gonna break your face oh it's
like doing it and no no anymore
yoga chair pose
you